let's bring in former house speaker newt
gingrich he is the author of the new
book beyond biden rebuilding the america
we love drops today mr speaker thanks
for being here glad to be here as you
look at this race
what do you see you know as it developed
and how how it's changed over the past
few weeks first of all
having been through a lot of these races
i'll feel better when i see the first
actual results as opposed to the polls i
think junkin probably gonna win but
you know we'll find out uh i saw a
brilliant contrast of strategies that's
really worth studying you had mcauliffe
who had been governor and knows virginia
well deciding he has to have a national
strategy because he has to beat him he
has to beat yunkan based on the national
patterns and you saw youngkin say you
know i'm going to run a state focused
strategy
and the two of them are totally
different campaigns
and then mcauliffe made the mistake of
saying parents shouldn't be involved in
schools and
that was probably the break point of the
campaign it was i think if in fact young
can wins a significant victory it will
have started at that debate well with
that mistake by mcauliffe you know it
looks like from our early fox news voter
analysis that yunkan is holding trump
supporters
in big numbers but also
getting a majority of those who didn't
support donald trump you write in your
book this all too many conservatives
have reacted to the rise of radicalism
within the democratic party with the
sense of despair they behave as though
losing the presidential battle of 2020
was the end of the great american
journey this simply isn't so we have
been here before and we have rebounded
we will win again is junkin tapping into
something that crosses that line that is
a blueprint for the midterms perhaps one
of the things i don't think any of us
fully appreciated is that the very
well-educated voter who tended to vote
for biden against trump
is also the voter who cares the most
about their children's education
and so when you get into the suburbs and
you start getting into things as we saw
with loudoun county and with fairfax
county all of a sudden it's the very
it'll be fascinating to see how what it
looks like when we get the actual votes
but i thought like the thousand people
who showed up in loudoun county
over the school issue
the many of those would normally have
been democrats but they're now so
frightened about their child's future
that as parents
they're probably voting for yunkan and
the younkin people have been very smart
the number of signs callista and i saw
today when we went to vote that said
parents for yunkan i mean that's a
that's a very smart cuts across all
party lines you know parents identify as
parents a lot more than they identify as
partisans mcauliffe was facing some
headwinds with the biden approval going
down with what's happening on capitol
hill which is kind of a mess
legislatively but how much do you think
that is a factor as opposed to the what
you're talking about here the students
parents
really a commonwealth issue i think
that would not have defeated mcauliffe
and again we i want to see the votes for
i've talked too confidently although i
do think young is going to win but i
think that the
the mistakes made by mcauliffe
uh
the the electrifi the electrifying
moment when he said parents shouldn't
have a role in schools and the young ken
people were good enough that within 12
hours they had a commercial up that had
just had mcauliffe and people looked at
that and thought well that's crazy and
then this weekend and as a somebody who
studied politics a long time and
practiced it a fair amount
i couldn't understand why he would say
that there are too many white teachers
because that it's a racist comment
and it's it's also misunderstands
northern virginia northern virginia is
not just black and white i mean it's
it's korean it's vietnamese it's chinese
it's latino you know very complicated
world out there and i think we want good
teachers of any background not bad
teachers of any background
if he falls short and it's a very tight
race maybe it's not even decided tonight
um and you know heading in this was a
tight race
is there a risk that's a lot of
republicans are going to say here we go
again yeah i think if it's a very close
race and about three in the morning
mcauliffe magically finds
five extra precincts
uh then i think you're gonna have a huge
backlash across the whole country
i think
you know
i've always had the position you have to
win big enough they can't steal it the
the burden on any republican is to never
get to a close race if you can avoid it
i think probably yunkan will do that
he's a very attractive personality and
he clearly has been having more and more
fun i i watched him last night and i
watched uh various places he's gone you
see him dancing you see him you've done
african campaigns you know that that
changes the dynamic at the end
especially yeah i think so and i think
that uh
i personally believe people
like politicians that they like
and i think that
mcauliffe is a very smart guy and been a
great professional politician for over
40 years
but mcauliffe looked
worried and scared and a little angry
and he was somebody said today i think
maybe the post of the new york times
that he had run a dark campaign you know
attacking about
january 6th attacking about trump and so
forth and that bianca increasingly was
running a happy campaign and i think as
a general rule in american politics
happiness beats darkness uh when you get
into these kind of races and again i'm
like i'm going to be watching you
as you go and start the count get the
raw data i think it's going to be a
fairly long evening and by the way we
should mention the national level the
the new jersey race has closed
substantially it's going to be very
interesting the the minneapolis vote on
abolishing the police department in the
middle of a crime wave is going to be a
very interesting test there are a lot of
interesting things going on out there
fascinating mr speaker thank you the
book beyond biden thanks very much thank
you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else